[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin now Europe will on Saturday be
saying its final farewell to former
German Chancellor Helmut called who
passed away two weeks ago many here in
Germany have been discussing his life
and his achievements the country's
longest-serving Chancellor is of course
credited with bringing about German
reunification and playing a key role in
the introduction of the single European
currency the euro for the first time a
politician will receive the tribute of a
special memorial ceremony at the
European Parliament in Strasbourg in
Berlin this week a Requiem Mass but no
state ceremony instead controversy over
helmet cause legacy so here on quadriga
this week we ask unifier Col what is his
legacy and to discuss that question I'm
joined here in the studio by vana Zhanna
who is who has for decades been one of
the most high-profile correspondents
reporting on German politics he says
Helmut Kohl will go into the history
books as the Chancellor of reunification
but there's also the power-hungry
politician who offended many and another
seasoned observer joins us Alan Posner a
regular commentator for the Berlin Daily
devel too argues calls legacy is the
eastward expansion of the EU and the
single currency the deepening and
broadening of Europe both of which are
now however in crisis and a warm welcome
to 2dw zone Hanna Cleaver who has also
closely watched Helmut calls career
Hanna says corporatism and corruption
were rife in the Kohl era Germany is now
more modern it's politicians can stand
up straighter interesting but I'd like
to begin with fairness honor and I've
got a quote for you Verner from Norbert
Lambert the Speaker of the German
parliament he says Helmut Kohl was a
stroke of luck for Germany and for
Europe do you agree yes I do 100% he was
the big unifier of Germany and he was a
big unifier of Europe and although he
did not start the German reunification
the people of East Germany did start
that process
and he did not complete the unification
of Europe but nevertheless he was an
extremely important element in the in
these two processes you experienced him
close up on many occasions what kind of
a man was he well you had a lot of
different sides to him it could be very
jovial he could be very friendly but you
could also be very even brutal to words
the people around him and I experienced
as a journalist all that from very close
up and this is part of his legacy also
mm-hmm
Alan I wonder what your strongest memory
is of Helmut Kohl so give us something
that sort of Qasim that tells us the
most about who he was
well I remember on the night the wall
came down or was the night after that
when he flew from he was in Poland when
he heard the news flew to Berlin there
was this big assembly in front of the
Chernabog a town hall where John F
Kennedy it held this ich bin ein
Berliner speech and and Brandt was there
and and the then mayor of West Berlin
and so on and there was this big crowd
of people who were jubilant at the fall
of the wall and call at the end of it
starts to sing the German national
anthem and you know you you can hear
they're all out of tune the others of
the other petitioners join and the crowd
is yelling and whistling against this
because that's not where Germany West
Berlin was at the time and I think that
shows something he was very definitely a
patriot and he immediately realized that
this is a patriotic moment for Germany
where that most of the Germans who were
very happy about what was happening
weren't on the same page with him and he
managed to bring him up to the same page
within a couple of months fairly you're
not ink yes absolutely I was with
something called in in Poland in Warsaw
that historic night and in all fairness
one has to say that night people around
him we're not thinking about German
reunification the
thinking about the thousands and
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people who would come to West Germany
and the question that night was what
will we do with all these people it was
a refugee crisis in the making yes
absolutely that was the sort on this
historic night but nevertheless a few
weeks later you already gave her the
famous speech where he was asking for a
confederation of the two Germany's which
very soon led to the idea that
reunification should come should come
along hanna cleaver bill clinton
he's been praising Helmut Kohl these
recent days but he said a little bit
early but I think it was 2011 he said
the most important he described Helmut
Kohl as the most important European
statesman since the Second World War
that's high praise indeed can you go
with it I think yeah certainly that's
not to say that there's no criticism to
be thrown at all but definitely the most
important I mean the whole of the
post-war European story has been
dominated by this Germany problem what
we do in Germany how do we handle a
country that started two world wars and
then came out of it effectively the most
dominant economic power in Europe what
do you do to tie down this Gulliver if
you like of European economics and power
and coal for all his faults and there
are many he really cleaned up shop if
you look at his very long career that's
effectively what he did he tie Germany
into the European Union he tied Germany
all of Germany into the European Union
and in a way and and took care of
business in many ways also to the east
of Germany which I think has often at
the moment not being talked about enough
how how much he did stress relations to
the east of Germany and in a way he is
passing I would say really does open up
German politicians the idea that they
can become more proud of being Germany
it's okay to be proud of being German
itand as Alan was saying when when in
the 80s and and even during most of the
90s if people were singing the journey
anthem it was a sign of fascism it was
hated most right-thinking Germans would
never do it and this generational change
we're you know since the World Cup 2006
you're allowed to be proud of being
German you're allowed to be you know
wave the German flag that is something
that was really not possible during
Cole's time and that whole era was this
kind of transitional area if you like if
you look at it from a historical
perspective to coming into Germany being
a normal country which it's been wanted
to do for a long time yeah I absolutely
agree I am so cool on a lot of occasions
and all the stress when you go to France
and you greet the French flag you do it
not just once you do it twice in other
words you make France bigger and
Germany's smaller that was is that was
his idea to make to make German
reunification possible the his idea was
is the way he thought was okay we need a
German reunification
that's an historic opportunity and you
grabbed it and then he understood that
Germany would be a giant inside of
Europe and therefore an economic giant
and people were very afraid round us
about that and he understood very well
that he had to make Germany smaller than
it actually was and and and the way to
do it was which is such a big man
yeah but but he fully understood that
and and and the way to do it was to
integrate this reunified Germany into
Europe there was his train of thought we
hear about his achievements we hear
about you mentioned his patriotism
already here's a question for you Alan
I'm sort of I wouldn't ordinarily ask
you but I wonder whether you personally
as a German feel grateful to Helmut call
for the miracle of reunification because
the reason I'm asking is because Helmut
Kohl complained and became bitter I
think it's fair to say over the fact
that in his estimation people were not
grateful they were ungrateful what the
first thing to say is he should have
been grateful for a reunification
because he was
he was a spent force at the time he had
been he'd been transfer for six years by
the time unification came around his
economic reforms had failed he'd wanted
to turn Germany into sort of a
Thatcherite Britain and instead it
become a sort of a red-green
paradise in spite of all the things he
said so
reunification gave him a second lease on
life so if anyone should be grateful it
should be him am i grateful looking back
no I mean he's he's a politician he was
the right man at the right time and
there were times right for him and and
gratefulness towards positions it what
what happens to everyone who stays on
too long it happened to church of it
happened to de Gaulle it is going to
happen to anger lemarchal and it
happened to call well you know that's
tough but reunification have happened
without him of course yes you of course
holding the East Germans were saying if
the Demark doesn't come to us we're
gonna come to the DMACC you're the
problem that they put on that first
evening as you told us was the problem
that forced the Germans say well you
know in order to keep them there let's
give them West Germany yeah well this is
certainly a very important element in
the whole and in the bigger picture I
I'm absolutely convinced that without
Helmut Kohl and others whom we
befriended like President Bush yes like
Gorbachev meter all to a degree this
process would not have been possible I'm
absolutely convinced of that and he had
this ability to befriend all these
people and and and and Trust was the key
word here they trusted him on both sides
in Moscow and in Washington and that
mate made it possible that these two
leaders President Bush on one on the one
side and on and GABA job on the other
side
allowed it to happen okay yeah there's
no doubt about it at all Hellmouth cold
certainly had a talent for forging
relationships that could prove useful
later and they did in the process of
German reunification it's also
interesting I suppose and if you want to
sort of understand Helmut call a little
bit more to have a look at the
relationship the strained to put it
mildly the strained relationship they
had with Angela Merkel let's do just
that
Helmut Kohl discovered Angela maca who
with his support rose rapidly through
the ranks of the CDU in 1991 she became
Minister for women in youth and later
Environment Minister Mackel admired Kohl
but she didn't like it when he called
her his girl after 16 years in office
Kohl lost the 1998 election and stepped
down as party leader because of the CDU
donation scandal which happened under
his watch he also withdrew as honorary
chairman Mackley distanced herself from
him she took up Cole's mantle and was
elected Chancellor in 2005 but her
relationship with Kohl remain difficult
despite calls from within the party maca
did not offer Kohl honorary party
leadership again but she paid tribute to
his achievements when he won the Henry
Kissinger prize in 2011 he said not one
word about her how much is angle amaku
like her one-time mentor
[Applause]
Alan tell us a little bit more about the
complex relationship between her might
call an angle a miracle two very very
different people
well I mean he's a Catholic from the
west of Germany and you know deeply
embedded in the Ardon our tradition of
some Rheinische capitalism and and
Europe as seen as Germany France and
she's and and of course he's a big man
and she's a woman from the East who from
a Protestant and by the way communist
background who has no emotional
relationship to anything cool stood for
so I think that's two very different
people and you've seen it in the way
Angela Merkel has handed Europe very
badly in my in my opinion because she
has she is a nationalist a Protestant
nationalist from Prussia where he was a
Rhenish European and so so I mean you
know you could hardly imagine two more
different types of people
mm-hmm and tell us a little bit about
because the key moment in the
relationship between Merkel and coal was
the the party donations scandal that
broke in 1999 tell us a little bit about
the scandal about her intervention in
that crisis and whether that
intervention was courage or opportunism
it was both she openly said it at the
time that we should not be afraid to
clear this whole thing up and that's
what she did and she did she was the
year Secretary General of the CDU at the
time and she distant the CDU from cold
she wrote an article and the Frankfurter
Allgemeine Zeitung at the height of the
scandal and she said the era of Helmut
Kohl is over kept the money though well
and it's an obvious fact that without
the scandal and and her standing up
against him she would not be the
Chancellor today because the scandal
cleared the way for her to be
the chairwoman of the city who just four
months later and their voice of course
the absolute necessary stepping point to
become the Chancellor later Hannah how
great was Helmut Kohl's full from grace
around the donation scandal I mean his
supporters suggest that really the whole
thing with just a sort of a footnote in
a great and another wise great life I
think it's actually overshadowed an
awful lot of his legacy I mean we're
talking about it now people are talking
about it on the day he died and they're
not gonna stop because it was it
Illustrated his arrogance when he stood
there and said I'm not gonna tell you
who gave me the money because I gave
them my word putting his own word and
his own sense of honor for him that
arrogance that what you call arrogance
was a loyalty a virtue he was putting
his own personal sense of honour above
the state above above his own party
above who the rest of his career I mean
it wasn't very smart move and I think
when Marko gave him the push it was
absolutely necessary
yeah totally agree I mean to say I gave
them my word of honor that's you know
it's like thieves honor the fact is
these illegal donations and cool any
other citizen of this country would have
been bound by law to help the
authorities clear up who gave this it
gave these illegal donations and he
seems to I gave them my word of honor
and and that's it it's really a huge
scandal and it's a pity because it
wasn't necessary I'm sure he didn't give
them his word of honor he just said it
because they didn't want people to know
who it was he just thought he would get
away with it he got away with it as far
as the law was concerned he hasn't got
away with it as far as his reputation is
concerned mm-hmm I just like to pick up
on a point that you made earlier about
about European policy because Helmut
Kohl was very possessive about the
Europe that he believed he helped to
create he was very critical of Angela
Merkel's role in dealing with the
eurozone crisis and the European
challenges of the last ten years or so
he said she's destroying my Europe she
has a no idea quote/unquote how unfair
was that it's totally fair as I said she
is a German nationalist
and you Cole always realized and
throughout his whole career you know and
the totally independent of my criticism
of his political of his personal
relationships he understood that Germany
has to cultivate the small nations of
Europe in order to you you talked about
that in order to alleviate the fear of
German dominance now
maca has used the euro and the euro
crisis to increase German dominance all
across the board economically
politically basically she's emasculated
the European Council
he's emasculated the European Commission
she's emasculated all the other
politicians of Europe and until Macomb
came around there was no one in Europe
who could stand up to her and Cole would
never have let even that impression
arise don't you think that's because he
was of his generation she is of hers you
know you had the Schroder stuff in
between of it you know we now have a
normal country Germany is finally after
70 plus years become a normal country
that can stand up and act in its own
interests and that's not Germany is
never going to be a normal country not
because of the Holocaust and all that
but because if you have 80 million
people in the center of Europe with this
huge industrial power you are not a
normal country like say
Sweden or even Poland the only other
country similar is Britain and we've
lost Britain also thanks to Uncle
America so now Germany is not a normal
country and cor realized that and and I
could maca doesn't she has no idea well
like you said I I really have to take
issue to portray Angela Merkel as a
nationalist I think has very little to
do with reality she actually had to
suffer in a way because Helmut Kohl
never finished the European process he
started it and and rightly so but
because of many reasons he never was
able to complete the necessary steps to
really unite Europe and and make it a
complete political and economic entity
and in that came about in
in 2008 when the financial crisis broke
and that had very much to do with the
deficiencies of Europe and it was not
her fault and also she certainly is the
strong leader in this Europe no doubt
about it one element is that Germany is
as big as it is but her strength is the
weakness of many many many European
leaders so what does led to a continuing
crisis in southern Europe it's led to
breaks it it's led to basically a big
division between Western and Eastern
Europe especially Hungary Vera and
Poland are most importantly Stern
neighbors so if this if that's the
result of her strong leadership
then she squandered everything called
stood for yeah we can we can debate for
half an hour or more about what happened
in great this is really Angela Merkel's
fault in the end or whether it was the
weakness of David Cameron we started
completely unnecessary referendum and
which brought about the Praxis anything
to do with Michael at all that's
Cameron's fault okay it's it's the
British fault not the Germans who you
know made this referendum happen okay
we're gonna move from the European
panorama back down to the local level to
what's been happening in the last couple
of days because in the last two weeks
there's been an unholy feud in the in
the over helmet called funeral his
legacy mainly within his family but the
question is is there a political
dimension to it all let's just find out
what's been happening first of all
Helmut Kohl deployed his family as
ambassadors of the policy he called of
spiritual and moral turnaround back to
traditional conservative values for him
the personal was always political but
the facade of the perfect family
crumbled
his first wife Honolulu took her own
life in 2001 his son Vita wrote a book
in which he said Cole had failed as a
father Helmut Kohl married Michael a
star 34 years his junior who had worked
in the Chancellery office some observers
accused her of further isolating her
husband from his sons vitae Cole refused
entry to his father's house the widow
Cole does not want to heal the rift
between father and sons even now who
will get to be the keeper of course
legacy it's a sad painful sorry story
Hannah what's the political dimension
it's just a disaster really for his
legacy and I think also going back to
the topic of his generation it kind of
shows what was demanded of people men
and politicians of that generation they
were not expected or even permitted to
have family lives private lives hobbies
I mean what did Cole do in his free time
does anybody know did he have any free
time he certainly wasn't spending it
with his he once said it was married to
the party or married to politics I'm not
sure which event I think it's a diamond
on that kind of professional politician
who has no life outside of politics and
I think from that political angle I
think it's a shame because I don't think
that makes for a particularly brilliant
politician I mean in many ways he was
fabulous but did he really understand
actual people he couldn't even hold his
own family together the unifier who
could not unify his own family your
thoughts that's a fully agree about that
assessment and there's not much to add
other than to say that it's extremely
sad and there are a lot of people who
really can't understand that and there
are few people who are to blame mm-hmm
as a member of sort of the generation of
the so-called 68 errs who've been
accused by the people around Cole of
being immoral
you know and wrecking the family and so
on and it's all balderdash I think this
was the whole hypocrisy of so-called
conservatism because they aren't
conservative you know cool had affairs
during his marriage married one of the
women he was having an affair with and
so on so fine as far as I'm concerned it
let but that just stopped the gab about
the moral rejuvenation of Germany
through conservative politics let us
stop that once and for all because it's
so distasteful and you can see this
family is not an exception this family
is typical of that whole hypocritical
post-war generation that that so hated
the sexual revolution of the 60s and I'm
really actually quite happy that that's
been exposed I was going to ask each of
you now for it's sort of in a nutshell
to give me sort of what is helmet cause
legacy but I I mean you said at the
beginning what Helmut Coulson Agassi is
it is German reunification that is the
cornerstone of everything about how much
in 50 years from now the history books
will tell you Helmut Kohl was the
unifier of Germany Helmut Kohl at a very
strong role in the unification of Europe
and nobody will talk about what whom he
married and why and and why not and what
was the party donation scandal let's go
back to German reunification you took me
you talked about it at the beginning I'd
like to get sort of 20 seconds from each
of you has German reunification being a
success story a genuine success story
overall it was and it is there are
victims certainly there out there who
lost a job who were lost there
they who saw that they lost their life
nevertheless it is a huge success story
in historic terms absolutely but many
people were losers of it and they need
to be made winners again still a problem
agree with story success story and an
ongoing you know task for us okay
thanks very much all throw Thea we've
been talking about the legacy of Pearl
McCall who will be buried on Saturday
thanks very much for joining us here on
quadriga look forward to seeing you next
week until then just
[Music]
you